[Music]
foreign good evening time then for the
Press preview it's our first look at
Monday's front pages and tonight we'll
check out the headlines with Kevin
Schofield who's the political editor of
half post UK our former conservative
special advisor Anita bote a very good
evening to both of you great to see you
we'll chat in a moment after we've had a
look at some of those front pages for
you we're going to start with the Metro
which says thousands of families fear
their Easter holidays abroad are at risk
as there are up to 19 hour queues the
paper is saying at Dover
the Ft reports on Saudi Arabia and other
nations cutting that oil production a
surprising to a surprising 1 million
barrels a day
the eyes warning NHS Mental Health Care
could face a public inquiry after a
family's experience of services
The Daily Star has the headline I love
you terminate marriage as it claims a
robot told a scientist to leave his
other half
all the times previews Rishi sunak's
plans for a task force to Target
grooming gangs
and don't forget as always you can scan
the QR code that you see on screen join
a program it means you can take a look
at Monday's front pages while you watch
us discussing them and to do just that
Kevin Schofield and Anita voting uh
really good to see you both this evening
thanks for joining us
um Anita why don't you kick things off
uh front page of the Times Child Abuse
gangs fed by political correctness so
it's all about Rishi sunak announcing a
task force to Target grooming
yes um so Nishi tsunaki is apparently
going to announce tomorrow plan to stop
um to Stamp Out grooming gangs
um with new data analysis so just to
clarify the point about political
correctness I think he is saying that
there has been some reluctance to
um record ethnicity of grooming gang
offenders
um which is obviously hampering the
ability to assess um who is posing risk
and how risk might be posed so I think
this is quite an important and sensitive
topic and it's only been the case that
data has been collected on the ethnicity
of groomers for about a year or so so
it's clearly very important that we get
a much more robust data set to enable
police to assess risk and to um manage
what is going to be and obviously a very
very sensitive and very very dark thing
that's happening in the UK yeah Anita
you think this is a sensible measure the
mandatory reporting now a duty for
professionals to to report and take
action they have to do it
yes I think that we need to have
confidence both in the protection of our
young people and that we are
understanding the scale of the problem
and of course we know all remember the
high profile cases in Rochdale and
Rotherham and those got a lot of
attention a while back but I think that
you know the fact that this has come
back again I think most people parents
Etc would want confidence that there is
a comprehensive plan for tackling this
and that we are looking at and
understanding the scale of the problem
because you know child sexual
exploitation is I mean it's not
controversial to say it's a deeply
shameful thing that um continues to
happen in the UK and we want to make
sure we're doing everything possible to
get that out
um and Kevin
um a bit of a row today about the
ethnicity of these gangs and and who
exactly is to blame
the Home Secretary was
um on the media room this morning and
she was announcing part of this bigger
package that's um being announced by
Rishi sunak tomorrow and she was really
pressing home uh her point that um as
she would happily believe most of these
gangs are
um men of of Pakistani origin now
unfortunately for her there's a home
office report from 2020 which actually
shows that most are are white now he's
trying to make a political point she's
blaming labor councils for
um not wanting to
um upset ethnic groups by um
investigating to uh closely this
Behavior which they which she says has
allowed this problem to
um Blossom effectively now she was
accused by the West Yorkshire mayor
Tracy Braven the labor mayor of West
Yorkshire of at dog whistle
um by mentioning this particular fact
now obviously this is your neck as you
see and tomorrow's going to be talking
about political correctness so he's
hammering home the same point which um
you know it's it's something it's very
it's a very sensitive area obviously
these are heinous crimes and and clearly
the government have decided that they're
going to go in quite hard on the
um ethnic background of many of The Men
Who perpetrate these things but I can
see that being very controversial I
think everyone agrees that this is a
problem which doesn't need to be
eradicated and but I think that the
government are waiting into quite
um uh controversial territory really by
focusing on the ethnicity of many of the
men involved yeah and as you say we will
hear uh more on this tomorrow let's move
on to the front of the I Anita I mean
not a day goes by where we don't hear
about the crisis facing NHS mental
health care in this country and the eye
has been speaking to the mum of a
patient who died in a mental health unit
yes and this is um a really big inquiry
that's been going on into patients who
died whilst being cared for
um in Essex as part of NHS Mental Health
Services
um and this was between sort of 2000 and
2020 and they found sort of somewhere in
the region of 1500 this paper Now
updates it to 2 000 patients who they
think have had circumstances that were
unexplained or unexpected or
self-inflicted in some way and it you
know it includes children and young
adults so it's incredibly important that
we get to the bottom of exactly
um what happened in this instance and
that we look at instances particularly
of mental health given what we are
seeing in terms of patterns of rising
concerns with mental health but we look
at the way that the NHS is dealing with
these cases and we're able to have
confidence that we are just as good at
dealing with broken bones as we are as
dealing with some of these acute mental
health concerns Kevin thank you
yeah I mean I I said it's a shocking uh
number 2000 debt and it's um it's it's a
shame really that it's taken uh outcries
from the families of those involved to
actually
um get to this stage but we are here now
which is a good thing and I think
anything that that sheds light on
um the extent of the problem and also
the quality of the
um care and the service being provided
by NHS Mental Health Services I think
it's got to be a good thing so that any
um issues can be highlighted
investigated and hopefully stamped out
so that other families don't don't go
through this um this awful experience
yeah absolutely right okay let's move on
to
um the problems down at Dover Anita
um I saw a tweet from someone I know a
mum who's on a coach with a load of kids
they got there at seven o'clock this
morning she tweeted at eight o'clock
this evening saying there was still
stuck the kids patience as you can
understand was running thin and as was
food and water and the Metro uh says the
Easter holiday delays fear over 19 hour
Ferry hold UPS
yes
honestly could not imagine anything
worse to being stuck on a coach in Dover
with lots and lots of school kids as
much as I adore school kids um so the
thing that's really curious about this
entire thing is that it doesn't seem
clear as to why this has happened and
according to officials according to the
reports in the paper that there have
been more people have arrived than
expected and there's some border
processing that's been slower it's all
very euphemistic I can't quite figure
out exactly how so many
um school children have been left in
this quite dire situation
um and there's been sort of rumors very
companies have said it's because of the
weather it's all very unclear but I mean
my heart very much goes out to every
single person who's had to be caught up
in these absolutely awful delays yeah
and Anita the front page of the times uh
talks about uh brexit and the fact that
there has been a clash over how much
brexit is to blame for the these delays
because
news uh was was dismissing that it was
an adverse effect of breakfast brexit
but of course on Sky also we interviewed
the ports chief executive who said it
was absolutely true
um so Anis what do you make of that
I I read the exact same reports and
couldn't quite figure it out I'm not
clear having not been on a ferry in a
little while exactly what the process
what would have changed about the
process
um and so I think that I need to
understand I certainly everyone who's
been following this story would like to
understand more about exactly
um how thick brexit might have changed
the process of just docking ferries
which seems to be to be the same
regardless
um so yeah a curious one yeah I suppose
the problem is Kevin that since brexit
every passport now has to be stamped so
never passed what has to be looked at
individually rather than just sort of
being able to get waved through and of
course that is time consuming
absolutely you've hit a nail on the head
there I think the reason for these
delays is is basically because yeah
every single passport now has to be
checked individually now previously and
passport's worth checked but you were
pretty much waved through because we
were part of the European Union now each
passport has to be individually checked
page after page going through to check
your stamps and then it needs to be
stamped now if you've got 50 or 60
people on a coach that obviously takes
an awful lot of time so so that is
basically the main reason effectively
now
um as you know the the vote to leave the
EU has resulted in
um we are now the external Frontier the
border at Dover is the external Frontier
of the European Union in much the same
way as there's a border with turkey or
there's a border with Russia and it's
treated as a hard border now that is the
brexit that the government chose to
implement and the unfortunately for all
the people caught up in it one of the
side effects of that is that um you have
much more stringent checks when you're
trying to get into the EU then we would
have done previously when obviously we
were also part of the EU yeah the paper
saying that a source close to the Home
Secretary later suggested the issues
were the result of how French officials
had decided to apply the post-brexit
checks okay thank you both uh for the
moment we're going to take a break
coming up after that supporters of
Donald Trump Gather in Florida to
demonstrate against the former
presidents indictment don't go away
[Music]
thank you
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Kevin and Anita still with us
Kevin why don't you kick things off for
this part and we'll start with the Daily
Telegraph and this explosion that's
happened in Saint Petersburg a military
blogger who is being killed he was a
very pro-russian campaigner
um tragically a a 20 25 or so others
have been injured but what's interesting
about this is is who's responsible
well you're right there's a there's a
debate as to who indeed is responsible
now um Russia are accusing Ukraine of
being behind it as you see this this guy
was an ultra nationalist was a real hate
figure and Ukraine had called on the
Kremlin to
um up the war
um be even more
um uh offensive in uh in Ukraine
um and they basically Russia are saying
that this was a Ukrainian assassination
effectively however you clean our as you
might expect denying any involvement and
the suggestion they're making is that
this is part of an internal Russian Feud
this guy was linked to uh the Wagner
group of um military uh group
um which which fights with for Russia
but for money they're a mercenary group
um and uh because he was linked to them
they've been involved in a feud with
Vladimir Putin themselves the suggestion
is that perhaps
um it could be a Russian assassination
so so yeah it's um it's rather confusing
but I mean it's a pretty incredible
development
um you know this guy was apparently
given um a talk
um to some supporters outside a bar in
Saint Petersburg when um he was a bomb
went off and he was um he was he was
killed but yeah it would be interesting
to see what the repercussions are from
because as I say there's um a lot of
discussion and um uncertainty as to who
was who was ultimately uh responsible
for it yeah I thought that he was hand
well there's video of him being handed a
little uh statuette and it's thought
there was an explosive device in there
there's also another theory Anita that
it could be a false flag operation the
Russians killing him so that they could
then blame Ukraine and use it for
propaganda purposes
yes and there have been some suggestions
I know as is well-known
um War correspondent tracker blogger
that he's been quite critical of the
Kremlin as well about their War efforts
and has exposed some military failures
so it could be sort of two birds one
stone for the Russian Administration
effectively being able to yes plant a
false flag and blame Ukraine but also
being able to get rid of someone who has
been um quite a vocal critic of some of
the ways in which the war has been
fought out now I should stress that this
is all very much speculation at this
point no one actually does know but it's
um quite disturbing
um and obviously incredibly tragic for
all of those who were injured as part of
this assassin or clearly seems to be
some kind of assassination attack in
Saint Petersburg
uh exactly right
um we'll find out more baps uh in coming
days let's move on to what is going to
be a very busy week uh in the United
States
um Kevin uh especially in New York
Donald Trump making his court appearance
on Tuesday he's going to fly up there
from Florida uh tomorrow evening and
then after the court appearance he's
going to address uh the media from his
home back in Florida just looking at the
front of the Ft Trump plays to Florida
fans is the headline a picture there of
some of his Base outside his home uh fix
America again that says the banner what
a week it's going to be
it certainly is and I'll be interesting
to see uh the next set of opinion polls
in America as to what this does for
Donald Trump's popularity because you
know remarkable as it may seem it may
actually improve his chances of of them
being elected again in 2024 it certainly
will fire up his base who believe that
it's uh it's a it's a these are pardon
upon trump top charges and that you know
he's been victimized
um and you know that they think that
they he's being um attacked by a
democratic establishment so uh in
ordinary circumstances uh situation
unless a politician facing criminal
charges you would think would ever it
would be curtains for their campaign but
Donald Trump doesn't seem to play by
normal rules we could actually help him
that being said it may actually scare
off a lot of moderate voters who maybe
voted for Trump back in 2016 and now
just don't want any more chaos in the
white house as I said it'll be
fascinating to see what he says
afterwards obviously you can imagine not
be very bombastic but it would be
interesting to see what the how it goes
down how it shifts or if indeed it does
shift their political opinion in The
Wider USA yeah of course in either the
charges still remain under seal so we
don't know exactly uh what they're going
to say yet
um uh and we know that there won't be
any handcuffs on Mr Trump um but there
will be mug shots there will be
fingerprints as well and quite the media
circus I'm sure or outside the courtroom
yes um and so he's in New York on Monday
and then we'll be
um in court on Tuesday and the thing
that frustrates me from across the pond
is that you can imagine that he's loving
being at the center of attention once
more you're absolutely right Kevin that
you know there is it's he's incredibly
divisive he remains so there's little
that I've seen in the um polling to
suggest that he is pulling people over
who weren't already supporters of him um
but at the same time the sort of trump
circus kind of rolls on and certainly
every minute that we spend talking about
Donald Trump I'm sure to him is is to
the good um so it will be an absolutely
fascinating week not least because as
you say Jonathan we don't actually know
what the charges are or they're related
perhaps to hush money that he paid
allegedly paid to the porn stars Stormy
Daniels but we don't know any of the
details and as that all unfolds I think
everyone will be watching the very very
closely indeed aren't they really well
and let's finish with the front of the
Daily Star I love you terminate marriage
robots are taking over the world a chat
bot has told a happily married man leave
the missus she doesn't want you um and
there is a sort of serious side to this
story Kevin in a way because
the rise of AI continues and there has
been this call this week for a
moratorium a halt if you like for six
months on increasing the power of AI
while we try and just sort of work out
where we're going with it because we
don't want the machines taking over
no we set my Dawn and um yeah that does
seem to be a bit of an arms race right
now across the world
um scientists trying to outdo one
another to create ever more powerful
um robots and yeah it is pretty
terrifying frankly
um so I can understand why there are
these calls for
um these experiments and this this um
technology technological progress to be
halted the thing is though once you've
started the ball rolling it's very
difficult to uninvent what is going on I
mean I don't think we can just basically
put AI back in its box and forget it
ever happened so we are on this road now
the question as you say is whether we
can control it or whether they become
the robots it's almost funny to say that
the robots become more intelligent than
we are and then well who knows what
might happen you're in the Realms of
Science Fiction then it could be quite
quite scary yeah uh this chatbot was
called Sydney the paper said it scared
the pants off a buffing by telling him
to dump his other half it's fatal AI
attraction which is quite clever um
thank you both very much we'll speak
again in half an hour right now let's
take a look at the weather